- So, wait, I have to say this.
You have a new addition,
since the last time we talked.
You have a little one now.
- I have a baby, yes. Cosmo.
He's about, I think 15
months old, 14 months.
The whole months thing has alluded me.
- I know, but you still
get the baby smell.
Mine are six and eight,
so I don't have baby smell anymore.
That's so cute.
- That's, yeah.
The baby smell is like, "I wanna just"
- Skin on skin.
And you just take them in.
- Delicious.
- I love it.
How did you come up with the name, Cosmo?
- Oh gosh.
Yeah. We just threw a
bunch of letters together.
- We're like, "That works."
- Yeah. It just seemed
like a really kind of,
I just thought it was so charming.
And then, you know, our
friends all liked it
and then Colin's mom had a little bit
of a harder time with it.
She was like, "This seems kind of."
She was, it wasn't sitting.
She kept suggesting other versions of it.
- Yeah.
- For a while.
And I was like, "No, he's
already here. He's out."
I was like, "It's passed that time."
- She's gonna have to
own it at this point.
I love that, though.
Because, is your daughter's Rose?
- Yes.
- My daughter's River Rose.
That's the only reason why I knew that.
But also I love that they're both flowers.
- They are both flowers.
- Yeah.
My kids hate plants of
how much I love them.
- Oh really?
- And flowers, yeah.
They're like, "Oh good, plants."
But I love flowers and plants.
And I thought that was kind of cool.
- Yeah. Yeah, that.
Not a lot of people make that connection.
But yeah, cosmos like a
really sweet, little flower.
Comes in different shades
of orange and yellow
and stuff like that.
That's why my daughter liked it, too.
- See, they're both flowers.